Jennifer is gonna start off this hour
she's in New Hampshire hi Jennifer
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
sir thank you for speaking with me today
sure what's up um so a few months ago I
had to check out night on my husband
he's an alcoholic who was abusive to my
children while I was at work I don't
know I don't know after all is said and
done so what do you what do you make of
your insurer job um I make a hundred and
ten thousand dollars and then I just
started a a per diem job so I can you
know I never have to pay for
babysitter's but I'll be able to to pick
up unlimited hours pretty much and so
your take-home pay on 110,000 announced
or what it's six thousand a month
excellent job and how much is your house
payment
it's three thousand dollars a month well
I mean I think that the important thing
is the kids are okay the important thing
is you're okay
house is just a stupid house there's one
on every corner home is where you make
it and so trying to hold on to a
particular physical location to make
everyone alright and that causes you to
go broke is is not going to be good for
you guys long-term and so you have a
house payment that's 50% of your
take-home pay you and me yep yeah
so it's painful as it is while you're in
the middle of all this other pain I I
don't want to give you bad news but I
you know bad news is is that you try to
hold on to this thing because you want
to keep the environment stable for the
kids and understand
situation and I appreciate mama bear
wanting to do that but the truth is it's
going to starve you to death
so in the short term everybody feels a
little better in the long term everybody
feels a lot worse and so if I'm you if
unless something changes dramatically in
your income you know I probably would
let I would probably would sell this
house now what is the house worth seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
what do you I want it a little over five
hundred okay so you got some equity for
a down payment on another property to
start again worse things have happened
to people okay your mate you you've
already made much harder decisions in
the last few weeks you've made harder
decisions than the decision to sell out
much harder agreed yes yeah it's just
that you've got pain upon pain upon pain
and this idea of yet one more piece of
instability just scares the crap out of
you which just makes you a good mom and
a good lady but your problem is your
math doesn't work you see what see what
I'm telling you trying to figure it out
yeah I wish I could wave a wand to make
you this go away for you but my wands
low on batteries and so yeah I wish I
wish I could figure it out I wish there
was a way to figure it out but there's
not really an equation where your house
payments half of your take-home pay that
ends up being anything but a nightmare
and you don't need another nightmare
you're just getting rid of one true 13
so I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I said what
I said what you already know didn't I
yes yeah I'm sorry I don't listen you're
gonna be okay we're gonna put you in
Financial Peace University and help you
handle money as you go through this
confusing and torn up time in your life
and you're gonna be okay five years from
now you'll be in a comfortable home
you've got a great career you're
household to be stabilized your kids
will be safe
you'll be safe and you've done the right
thing
you can't allow people no matter who
they are to have access to children who
are going to bring harm to children it's
just not an hour it's not an option so
you've done the right thing you've made
some really hard decisions you're very
brave you're very courageous but you
made the right one so far so keep making
the right call we'll walk with you kiddo
you call me anytime
Kelly I'll pick up right now we'll get
you signed up for Financial Peace
University and we'll walk with you
through that part of it I can't fix
everything but I can fix that part and
help you with it so thanks for the call
let me just tell you if you're going
through a divorce and nobody wants that
and I would never recommend divorce I
certainly would recommend keeping
someone away from a lady or her children
who was being abusive got no use for
that at all and so but if somebody's
going to go through that most of the
time statistically speaking you bought
your house based on income that is not
going to be in the house anymore
and so affording the house after the
divorce is an unusual thing it usually
doesn't happen you usually need to sell
the house but it's normal because we
don't want the kids to change school
systems their friends are all there
they've already got all this upheaval in
their lives and we want to protect them
from any more people any more volatility
any more emotional pain but you can't
you can't they're going along for this
ride because you're gonna you're going
to trade one kind of emotional pain for
another one is later on they're going to
be broke you're gonna be broke you can't
afford clothing you can't afford the
college debt you can't afford their
college tuition you can't afford to live
there's your house pour at some normal
transactions in most case studies that
we see